now the song you recorded mother yeah
you say you recorded mother because of
me yes I thank you Howard me a better
mother yeah because you talk a lot about
your relationship with your mom and your
therapy right and being a mom you know
you media I've always been such a
laid-back easygoing person and then when
you have kids and you have the
responsibility of these two people's
lives it brings on a lot of pressure and
stress right and anxiety but you've
always made me very conscientious of not
putting that on my kids I was gonna play
the song that you did mother
yeah but Fred says he can't play it on
guitar
you want to try singing it live sure
right Fred now who knows how this will
work Fred are you gonna [ __ ] this up who
you feel like Fred are you nervous of
course I'm nervous I mean cuz you got a
world-class singer Lee that's what I'm
saying usually you play from me or your
world-class singer too yeah but but you
feel you feel confident to play this
song if it sucks then just play the CD
it's any point you feel it sucks pull
the plug I'll not be inside let's try
let's try
[Music]
thing to drop the bomb
[Music]
well do you think they like this stuff
[Music]
mother do you think they'll try to break
my balls
[Music]
mother should I run
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mother should I trust
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mother will they put me in the fiery
[Music]
is it
[Music]
baby babe
[Music]
Mama's gotta be go
Mama's gonna
Mama's gonna keep you
won't let you fly but she might let
Mama's gonna keep baby
healthy and clean
[Music]
baby
[Music]
mr. small
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you think she's good enough
[Music]
mother do you think she's dangerous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but will she tell you
little boy
[Music]
[Music]
you break my heart
[Music]
hush now baby baby
surprise
[Applause]
Mama's gonna check out
mama
[Music]
Mama's giveaway
till you get it
[Music]
where you've been
Mama's gonna keep
a cozy
baby
[Music]
mother do me
be so high
Wow I was so nervous during that
oh I mean Fred were you nervous during
that of course yeah I mean I was sitting
on pins and needles